welcome back to New Rockstars it's me
Tommy B in season two of the bad batch
is beginning to wrap up we have two
fresh episodes to talk about that's
right it's time for another bad boy
breaking down bad batch episode 12 The
Outpost is not what I would call the
most light-hearted Star Wars Fair we're
a long long way from those little Ewoks
dancing on Endor but it does bring us up
to speed with Crosshair and also has ice
vultures in it so I'll take it speaking
of taking I am taking advantage of all
of these incredible merch options at
nerd riot.shop especially are the way
collection I am partial to the foundling
shirt of course we also have some
exciting new stuff coming to nerd rat
dot shop in the future I can't exactly
confirm one but let's just say I'm a
Barbie girl in a Barbie world you know
what I'm saying dogs it's about to be
pink around here now also subscribe to
the Deep dive everything everywhere all
at once just lit up the Oscars and Eric
has an incredible deep dive into that
movie that is worth your time to check
out all right we begin at the Clone base
on Coruscant and the Clones are being
phased out as part of the previous
storyline where Rampart plotted to
retire the clones and then blew them up
and then the emperor managed to get a
conscription Army passed through the
Imperial Senate the Clones are being
well wished by a very cold clearly
rehearsed speech given by an imperial
officer now this kind of reminds me of
how soldiers have been treated
historically throughout history they do
their job they sign up they risk their
lives and then they're kind of ushered
away in a pretty non-ceremonial way for
the most part the conscripted Army has
already begun moving into the bases we
see some TK Stormtroopers you can tell
by their gen 1 helmets see I'm learning
commenters marching along the Empire is
moving very quickly to a race any memory
of the clone troopers we do get a quick
shot of the Clone memorial wall during
the day but that can't be too good for
business so my guess is that will be
destroyed or removed soon Crosshair
heads to Barton 4 a miserable icy Planet
so Bleak and hopeless looking that I
almost expected to see my uncle Jimmy in
front of an ice cave waving a Buffalo
Bill's flag crosshairs joined by
Lieutenant Nolan one of the most
obnoxious commanding officers I've seen
in any Star Wars property and that's
saying something because we had General
Hawks I suck this guy is used to hammer
home that point that once a soldier is
seen is unuseful they are treated with
contempt and looked at as useless we
meet Commander Mayday and his remaining
troops who have been basically stranded
on this Outpost with Mayday noting they
expected them 36 rotations ago see they
don't value the Clones anymore they'll
just leave them freezing there because
they see them as obsolete technology now
a guy named Mayday stuck on a snowy base
fearing that he has abandoned is a
little on the nose but that's what I
love about Star Wars they're not afraid
be a little bit on the nose for you in
this one scene we see no one won't even
accept help from a clone trooper as he
slips on his way off the ship this guy
sucks he keeps referring to them as
equipment I hate this I noticed Mayday
and his crew have created a memorial
using the helmets of their fallen fellow
clones this is kind of a repeated theme
with clones creating memorials like the
one on Coruscant that we saw earlier to
honor their fallen Brothers Mayday and
Co are attacked by Raiders and they
suffer even more casualties Crosshair
tries to take out a few Raiders but he's
blinded by an explosion the reason being
he's wearing his infrared helmet and the
explosion just absolutely lights up his
eyes just like his brother Hunter
Crosshair has enhanced sight so limiting
his vision is a major obstacle and maybe
a foreshadowing into the future as a
result of maybe having some damaged
Vision temporarily across here steps out
of mine as he and Mayday pursue the
greatest Mayday is able to improvise a
tool to free Crosshair while trying to
extol a little wisdom on him
oh I'm confident
okay I'm not stupid sometimes when you
love a show or a movie it's not enough
to have seen it you need some merch to
commemorate the occasion and nerd riots
got you covered baby if the finale of
The Last of Us left you hungry for more
pick up a lunch of us tea available in
cream or black featuring the logo of
Todd's Steakhouse from episode 8 of the
series
um don't eat there though just don't do
that unless you're a cannibal if you're
stoked for the upcoming John Wick movie
nerd Riot has a whole lot of John Wick
shirts to make you feel like you've got
a seat at the high table there's the
Baba Yaga team my personal favorite a
gun Chuck's tea a tea for the high table
itself for claiming I have served I will
be of service get them all now and you
can wear them opening night and then you
can wear them again the next weekend
when you see John Wick chapter four for
a second time and of course if you're
obsessing over the Mandalorian right now
there's a whole line of Mando merch in
the way collection with teas beanies
hats even stuff for the kids there's a
lot of new fun exciting merch coming up
and I can't give away too much but let's
just say it's Barbie's World we're just
living in it to get your hands on the
merch you need head to nerd riot.shop
today join the riot over at Nerf
riot.shop
Mayday isn't totally Southwest he does
move away before Crosshair steps off you
know Casey explodes mating Crosshair
attack the Raiders who have tons of
Trooper attack including Electro staffs
Crosshair shoots a stack of landmines to
finish off the Raiders and it also
triggers an avalanche the two work
quickly to escape but they're both in
bad shape badly injured that you
discover the gear that they were going
after is armor for the new conscripted
Army Mayday begs Crosshair to go on
without him but Crosshair can't leave
him behind because he owes him you know
for that whole landmine thing and we see
that Crosshair does you know he cares
about people who help him he's just you
know also a ruthless killer they make it
back but Mayday is too far gone no one
continues to act like a jackass about
time you two returned so Crosshair kills
him crosshairs arrested and taken to
mount Tantus presumably to Dr Hemlock so
he can scramble his brain even further
oh God don't make Crosshair even more
dangerous please I just wanted to be
back with the badge the next episode
episode 13 Pabu starts with the bad
batch hanging out in a Cantina and it's
a who's who of aliens Ryan Aries
excellent breakdown identifies the bar
as Club loshe who was a villain in an
Indiana Jones movie and that's cool
because this opening sequence has major
Indiana Jones Vibes outside the Cantina
we see biffs nivians Twilights and damn
inside we see an aqualish dressed like
the Kenner action figure we are reunited
with fee who's played by Wanda Sykes as
she makes a deal with a pirate named
Crowder who then tries to poison her
with wine and then uses the same bugs
Jango Fett was using to try to kill
Padme again poison wine poison insects
Indiana Jones Vibes like I said the gang
escapes the fee and then they
communicate with Sid overcomes we have
this great scene where Sid is breaking
up her voices modulating low and high
she's had it with a bad batch they've
had it with her friendly Sid Rio Perlman
Carla from cheers she's ready to turn on
him I mean this has been hinted at all
season and it won't be long I think
before Sid sends the Empire after the
bad batch so where do they go they go
where you gotta go when you want to get
away from your troubles Pabu baby and
let me tell you one look at this place
and I am getting major Kingdom Hearts
Vibes I'm started planning on starting
missions I was gonna go jump into Winnie
the Pooh world I was going to jump into
Toy Story world I was gonna go jump into
Nightmare Before Christmas world one
time Pabu we see is actually liberating
treasure just like Omega says she is
Indiana Jones she's taking these
treasures and she's putting it in a
place they call the archaea is that for
Ark of the Covenant or is that for
Noah's Ark is there some kind of
biblical themes including a man named
Shep could be short for Shepherd and his
daughter Leanna this leads us to a
sequence of the bad batch hanging out
with the people of Pabu that I find
truly hilarious wrecker is finally full
now that is the biggest twist in bad
batch history that wrecker has finally
eaten enough food that he feels full of
course then they reveal that it's time
for dessert and he has a little extra
room in his stomach which I can
empathize because I've been to plenty of
Pizza Huts after baseball games and
eating all that pizza just in time for a
hot pan brownie you know what I mean and
then Echo makes a joke he says I'm gonna
note this moment as if record being full
is truly hilarious to him Hunter senses
that something is about to go wrong on
Pabu and he's right because the Munoz
these cute little monkey creatures are
running around panicking you know like
dogs before a storm or an earthquake
that's right there are Tremors first a
little Tremor and a major one that
causes a flood unfortunately Omega and
her new friend Lila are out at Sea and
Omega is experiencing things for the
first time we forget Omega has not had a
childhood this is like the first person
her age that she's ever hung out with
and of course there's a massive Title
Wave Hunter takes the Morata out and
rescues both Omega and Layla the bad
batch are offered the opportunity to
stay on Pabu so they say okay we'll do
that which means to me the Empire is
probably coming in about two days to
kill all of them so I think we're
heading towards Crosshair being
reprogrammed by the Empire and hunting
down the surviving members of the bad
batch and then the bad batch rescuing
him saving him and all of them being one
big happy family flying into season
three do you think I'm right let me know
in the comments please don't forget to
like the video and subscribe to new
rockstars follow me at Tommy Bechtel
don't forget to subscribe to the Deep
dive for all of those sweet sweet deep
Dives that only Eric Voss can do I have
spoken
[Music]